I
Only furniture at this moment surgery establishing control over this continent and every person on it
My allies are gone. I'm losing you can count on the iron back as soon as the gold arise
enough with the Clever plan
Hey guys new episode just ended and while we fulfill our
Expectations as well as a few predictions and theories it has also after sanctions once again in waiting for the next episode
In my next video I will break down the third episode in details, but firstly let's break down preview for the 4th episode
It starts with Cersei Lannister
revealing her venture which is
Reestablishing control over westeros and every person on it as it's been
Expected the iron Bank will play a huge role in the war between the two Queens
later in review representative of the Iron Bank of Braavos
Promises to cersei that she can count on their own bank as soon as the gold arrives which will not arrive and therefore the iron
Bank will not fund cersei in this war
While it might seem like Cersei will manage to repay the debt of the iron throne
I think we should reconsider that
Jaime and randall with their armies are marching back home with the carriages full of good full of gold and food loaded from Highgarden
However the spoils of war including gold with which Cersei will repay the debt and with which she would basically
Persuade the Armed bank in the funding curve will never even reach King's landing not to mention
Cersei long story short while heading home Daenerys his army will attack
Jaime's and Rebel army and take an opportunity to fight them on the open field as
It's been mentioned a few times for the series norma can stand a chance against the track in the open field let's say viserys targaryen
lands with
40,000 Dothraki screamers at his back we hole up in our castles
wise Move
Only a fool would meet the dothraki in an open field and in an exam bush will obviously result it for victory
Daenerys writing Drogon will lead the track into huge battle new finalists set a tough blow for Cersei
not only that sir civil lost most of Lannister Army
But one of her only allies will be destroyed as well and all spoils contain a food and goal
That should see their men had repaid the debt of the crown will be lost
During this battle randall and entirely are going to get captured while bran will save Jaime from almost getting killed upon
They're going to escape in the heat of battle
It is it assumed that randall is going to be burnt alive by Danish dragon as a result of rAndall's betrayal over his own house
Tyrell and for pledging his army to search his cause
randall Santak entirely on the
Handle most likely get a chance to bend the knee and swear fealty to her because of the nares said herself in the last episode
the child should not be judged by the sins of their father and
I ask you not to judge a daughter by the sins of her father
There are also quite a few shots from
Dragonstone in this preview first let me have the nearest accompany with the king in the North stand their advisors
The mother of Dragons is reconsidering the whole plan of her conquest over the seven kingdoms
And is most probably in that same moment finally deciding to involve her dragons in war
Just as I predicted in my last video varys interrupted the meeting between John and Daenerys by informing his screen about her sweet being
intercepted and destroyed by Euron Greyjoy
Even though I thought varys would find it out about Feos arrival of the shores of Dragonstone
Cn will arrive in the following episode then we have John engineers visiting a mass mountain of Dragon West on Dragonstone Island now
We have the most interesting shot of littlefinger pulling out an elaborate dagger made of Valyrian Steel and the Dragon Bone hilt
I don't think baelish is pulling it out on someone to kill but I do think this is being favored to the white wedding theory
of mine in each area both slit little fingers throw to this same dagger and
Finally after all those years re arriving home in the next episode
I hope you guys enjoyed this video to this please make sure to subscribe to this channel
And I hope to see in the next piece